all right
now i'm going to show you how to solve
the constrained least squares problem
actually it's going to turn out to be
very much like the least squares problem
that we'll reduce it to something that
involves our old friend the qr
factorization
or solving linear equations let's see
how that works
so we'll start with a derivation from
uh calculus um that is if you remember
this but
it actually after this i'm gonna give
you a derivation which
frankly i find much clearer and is much
simpler
so but we'll start with this one because
it's traditional and after all
most of you or many of you were already
tortured by you know by taking having to
take a calculus class
and so we might as well go back and and
use uh use what you learned there
okay so um what calculus says
is something like this it says if you
want to solve this optimization problem
here
then what you're going to do is you're
going to produce something called the
lagrangian function that's named after a
famous mathematician named lagrange in
fact
i think his name already came up once
already in lagrange polynomials for
example
okay so and what what the lagrangian is
this
is this is you introduce these numbers
z1 up to zp
these are called lagrange multipliers
and it says that you should take the
objective function
here and you should add um that's the
constraint because these are like these
are the constraint residuals
these things c one transpose x minus d
one into c p transpose x minus d p
and we multiply those by the lagrange
multiple and that's the lagrangian
okay now um anyway then then what you're
told
is this is the optimality conditions are
simply this you take the partial
derivative of the lagrangian with
respect to x i
that has to be zero and the partial
derivative with respect to all the zi's
have to be zero
okay so i actually remember being taught
this
and having absolutely no clue what it
meant
um i don't know that i actually really
learned it until maybe i was in grad
school
or something like that to really get it
now in this class we're not going to get
in we're not going to get into what it
really
what it is so we're not going to do that
but you know if you take a course on
optimization maybe that maybe at that
point this will become clear
and in fact it's funny because it's
actually normally just taught as a set
of behaviors
or tips it's like you want to solve that
fine form the lagrangian set the partial
is equal to zero
and if you ask why they're like just do
it so okay
that's that was my experience anyway so
if you feel the same way that's fine
okay um so let's look at these
conditions well the first one
says i should take the partial the
second one i should say takes the
partial respect to zi and set it equal
to zero
and if i take the partial derivative
with respect to say z one
i simply get c one transpose x minus d
one is zero
uh okay so i get these but we knew that
right that's the constraint that's
so we knew that that okay so so the the
second set group
of of of equality is the partial
derivative
of l with respect to the zi's is just
basically reaffirming
that we can't we have to choose
something that is uh feasible
okay now the first n equations are those
are more interesting
that's the partial derivative of l with
respect to x i
um and when you go back and work out
what it is we have to take the partial
derivative of l with respect to x i and
you can see there's
contributions in here but there's also a
contribution in in here
and that's actually a calculation we did
before i'm not going to do it right now
but it turns out to be exactly this it's
times the sum of a transpose a i j x hat
j
minus 2 8 a transpose b sub i plus this
these are the terms that come from those
other terms uh the the
the other terms where the dual variables
are the lagrange multipliers that's this
thing
okay um in matrix vector form you get
this equation
that is going to be that's the second
set of
of of equations that have to be
satisfied you know when you take the
derivative
of lagrangian okay so
this one i can write as c x hat
equals d and this one i write this way
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to collect
this equation equations system of
equations
this set of equations and i'm going to
collect them into one
big equation for both variables the
x hat and the z now the truth is we
don't care about the z
i mean i mean in some applications you
do care about the z but that's beyond
the scope of this course
we don't care about z so z is just
something you have to calculate
in order to get x hat so that's fine so
what we'll do is we'll we'll calculate x
hat
and z and then we'll just throw away z
and use x hat so
all right so let's see that i've done
this correctly when i stacked these two
equations
well the bottom equation is c these are
block multiplications i'm doing now
c x hat plus 0 times z is d
oh so the bottom one just says is this
okay
the top one is 2 a transpose a x hat
plus c
transpose z equals 2a transpose b hey
that's exactly this
okay so this this
this this set of equations here
expresses basically these uh
these lagrange conditions the lagrange
conditions are well
these things written out in a general
form that the partial respect to x i
is zero partial with respect to z i is
zero okay
and we get this and these equations
have a name they're called the kkt for
karush kun tucker these are three
mathematicians
who did some work on this actually what
they did was something much more
sophisticated with inequality
constraints
but nevertheless we would call these the
kkt or karush kuhn tucker
conditions and that's a square
set of n plus p linear equations in the
variables
which indeed have size n plus p
so that's a square set of n plus b
equations
with n plus p variables
and one very good way to think of this
equation is it's a generalization of the
normal equations for least squares
to constrain least squares so remember
that the normal equations were something
like a
transpose a x hat
you know equals you know a transpose b
that these are the normal equations and
that's actually
that's what this equation comes down to
um
if you remove c i mean that's what it is
you divide by two as well
so so you can think of this as this is
this is the kkt
equations are the um
the extension of the normal equations to
constrained least
uh squares right so that that's what
this is these are called the optimality
conditions or something like that
okay by the way this is very cool
because
um you know what we've done is we have
reduced
solving uh a a problem that we didn't
know how to solve which is
constrained least squares problem um
to one we do know how to solve which is
solving linear equations
right so that's that's that's a that's
kind of our trick
the truth is we kind of did it with
least squares as well so
okay now assuming that that
kt matrix is um is invertible um then
you just solve for x hat and z you do
something like this
um and that's the solution now we don't
care about z
um but we we do get x hat and that's
great so we have a way now to solve
uh to solve constrained least squares uh
problems now
um i mean one simple method simply takes
that matrix
and just solves it and which you could
do by for example
qr factorization of that now you might
be interested in when
this matrix is invertible and that
really means when is your constrained
least squares problem
sensible roughly speaking right and
i'm not going to go into the details but
it comes down to this c
has linearly independent rows and then a
stacked on c
has linearly independent columns and and
you'll see that this kind of
well first of all it implies something
about the sizes of various things right
um it says that the number of
linear equations has to be less than
dimension of the variable well sure okay
in other words the cx equals d equations
have to be
underdetermined or squared they're
square it's a bit silly but
because you just solve it and then
that's your answer
and the cost of computing it uh
there's many ways to do it one is just
to solve for this thing
and it's basically like n plus p cubed
is what it is right so um
that's that's how fast you can compute
it so okay
now what i want to do now is give what i
think is a far
better derivation of the solution of the
constrained least squares problem
and it uses nothing but like the most
elementary matrix vector notation
and deep mathematical concepts like you
know the sum of two non-negative numbers
is not negative
okay so i and it also doesn't require
any faith the truth is if you go back
to this to this story this lagrangian
story
um we were lucky in that there was only
one solution of these right it's the kkt
system or something like that but in
general
the real story in calculus goes like
this
you can find points that satisfy these
which are not
optimal right so roughly speaking this
lagrangian method says i can give you
some candidates and then it's your job
to go figure out if they're actually
optimal or not
that second question actually a lot of
people don't even they forget about that
um here this will just be a completely
independent verification
very elementary goes like this
so i'm going to show you that x hat is a
solution x hat
is is this one it's the one that says
it's that it's the x that
it's this one given by this i'm going to
show you that's the solution
okay to do that i'll say suppose x
is any vector at all that satisfy c x
equals d so you we would say
any feasible vector satisfies the
equations
okay then uh and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to show you that the norm
squared of x minus b
is bigger than is bigger than or equal
to the normal square root of ax hat
minus b
and then that'll show immediately that
that's that
my x my alleged x hat
absolute and my alleged solution x hat
is really the solution okay
so normal x minus b i do the same trick
we did with least squares
um i i take that and i do something
silly i
add ax hat um and i add ax hat here
okay and i subtract it which is silly
but now i'm going to use this formula
for
the norm squared of two vectors it's the
norm squared of the first
plus the norm squared of the second and
then plus two times the inner product of
the vectors
so the norm squared to the first is this
norm squared of the second is that
um and then i have this i have this
inner product that's the inner product
of the two vectors twice the inner
product
okay now what we're going to do is we're
going to u we're now going to use so if
i haven't used anything about x hat but
now i
am x hat satisfies this equation
right because that that's the first row
of the kkt system
okay that's the second row and cx
and cx hat both have to be d because
they're both feasible that's our
assumption
well sorry x hat is feasible by
construction
x is feasible by assumption okay
so what this says is if i look at this
inner product here
and i work out what that is i get 2 x
minus x hat transpose here i'm i'm
pulling the a
out here and then putting it over here
to a transpose
then i look at a transpose times a x hat
minus b that's right up here
that's c and i get this thing
and then i go over here and i get minus
c times x minus x hat
now c x i can tell you this c x is d
c x hat is d because they're both
feasible so
c times x minus x hat
is actually it's d it's actually d minus
d
so that's this thing is zero um and that
says
this this thing is just zero so it's
gone and then what this says
is that the norm of ax minus b squared
here is it is actually equal to this
it's the norm of a x hat minus b
squared plus and then this thing is
non-negative
so that means that it's bigger than this
so i'm done
so which is kind of cool so that's uh
that's it's that simple it didn't use
any anything complicated
so that's a direct verification that the
solution of the constrained least
squares problem
um is given by this right this
this is and this is a formula but it
doesn't matter uh you could you
you can compute it uh many things
actually a lot of linear algebra
packages would have
a function that would solve the
constrained least squares problem um
well you can write one yourself and it's
about
two lines long right it just sets up
forms the kkt matrix
then you know solves it with you know
backslash or something like that
so okay
now let's turn to the least norm problem
we'll see a beautiful thing emerges and
something pretty cool that ties a lot of
the stuff we've seen together
so the least norm problem says minimize
norm x squared subject to c
x equals d well some pretty cool things
happen number one
when we form the kkt matrix which is
this um
it's actually if assuming c has
independent rows
uh this matrix is always invertible uh
so because
i stacked on top of c has independent
columns i mean of course because of the
if you look at the i
on top we're going to assume c has
independent rows and that says you get
this
now here this system
generally speaking when you see a system
of equations the right thing to do
is don't try to solve it by hand
mistake let a computer do it
now there are exceptions sometimes when
something is
simple enough that you know well this is
in the case of that
um then it's time to get out your pencil
and do some algebra and stuff like that
now
um here the first equation says
basically
2x hat uh plus c
transpose z equals zero
and that tells us that x hat is minus
one half
c transpose z now the second equation is
c
x hat equals d and i simply plug in this
value of x hat and i get this
that gives me z so i know z is minus 2
c c transpose inverse d
and i plug that into the first equation
and i end up
with this uh x is equal to c
transpose times cc transpose inverse
times d but that's our friend that's our
c remember is wide
and this is precisely the pseudo inverse
so
it says that the solution of the least
norm problem is the pseudo-inverse
times the right-hand side that's it so
very cool
um so what this says is if a matrix c
has
linearly independent rows um then
we already saw well a while ago that's
that the
that the pseudo inverse of that matrix
is a right inverse of c we already saw
that um
uh and what that tells you you know is
that for any d at all
if you plug in x hat equals c dagger d
that satisfies c x equals d that's what
it means to be uh you know a
a a right inverse right but now we know
more
this is a special right inverse and it
is the right inverse
it says that x hat which is is is ace
a solution of c x equals d it's really
cool now we know it's actually the
solution with the smallest norm
so so it gives you the smallest solution
of cx equals d so it's very nice ties
a bunch of stuff we've seen together and
of course you can compute this by a qr
factorization on c transpose right so
that's all so everything sort of ties
nicely
together